bonjour à tous alors effectivement
monsieur monsieur d'estomac beaucoup
parlé de saint barthélémy mais selon
brière vous avez vous avez pu retracer
un tableau real en tout cas de la guyane
est franchement en tant que gay yanez
j'accompagne les pêcheurs qui maquille
ce en pleine détresse et donc j'aimerais
aussi que vous m'apportez quelques
éléments de réponse dans le cadre du
plan 2022
2027 en termes d'investissement puisque
vous avez fait remarquer effectivement
que la flotte est complètement
abîmé et quand on parle l'attractivité
pour l'information des jeunes c'est vrai
que comment peut-on attirer des jeunes à
une formation de la mer lorsqu'on voit
le matériel et à du matériel
voila j'aimerais bien comme apporter
quelques réponses quelques conseils dire
alors en guyane particulièrement il y a
eu déjà une pêche forte qui
malheureusement s'affaiblit mais du coup
les outils de transformation sont déjà
sur place vous avez le lusine de la
coupe du maire en particulier qui est
qui est un très bel outil qui fonctionne
très bien d'ailleurs financée en partie
par les fonds européens
donc
voilà enfin en guyane en particulier
puisque c'était votre question des
outils de transformation sont là il ya
vraiment une urgence à renouveler les
bateaux des scissions si on s'arrête au
moins de 12 mètres on n'aura pas
renouveler les bateaux qui sont utiles
au développement de la guyane